[Música]
cuando hace unos meses me plantearon
tener esta intervención de esta charla
con este título limitless inmediatamente
surgió en mi mente por deformación
profesional como filosofía y brett
hiciste una pregunta y un
cuestionamiento en torno al mismo título
limitless
somos realmente sin límites somos seres
ilimitados
nuestro obrar nuestro pensar tiene
límites
a raíz de estas preguntas y partiendo de
mi experiencia personal y profesional mi
trayectoria mi vida
pensé realmente mi experiencia me lleva
a constatar permanentemente que yo soy
limitada que tengo limitaciones
corporales que soy vulnerable que soy
frágil que sufro padezco lloro
los límites forman parte de la
experiencia común de cada uno de
nosotros
envejecemos sobre todo cuando ya tenemos
cierta edad vamos viendo vamos notando
los signos de la vejez o de ir hacia la
vejez es decir es un hecho que somos
limitados y eso será en nuestro cuerpo
lo constatamos cada día la conciencia
del límite es una experiencia
antropológica común
por otro lado si lo pensáis bien
corporalmente tenemos esos límites pero
al mismo tiempo en la dimensión
intelectual y la dimensión de nuestra
libertad es decir lo que son las
facultades propiamente humanas tenemos
la capacidad de plantear la superación
de esos límites es decir se da como una
paradoja la experiencia del límite
corporal y por otro lado el deseo de
superar los límites
para ir de alguna manera hacia la mejora
en el plano del conocimiento del conocer
la verdad de contemplar la belleza de
hacer el bien de obrar la justicia de
hacer cada vez cosas mejores que mejoren
nuestra sociedad y que nos permitan
vivir mejor hay algún autor que desde la
antigüedad nuestros días ha hablado de
la nostalgia de infinito en el ser
humano hay una suerte de nostalgia de
infinito por la que permanentemente está
en tensión hacia algo mejor bien y desde
el punto de partida la primera reflexión
que os quiero ofrecer más de carácter
digamos antropológico filosófico
hay un paradigma cultural denominado
transhumanismo que representa el deseo
de superación del límite y de ir hacia
lo infinito
ese paradigma es el paradigma trans
humanista
con esta diapositiva que muestra de
alguna manera supuestamente lo que ha
sido la evolución y hacia dónde vamos
yo la cuestiono claramente pero bueno de
alguna manera representa lo que dicen
los trans humanistas que estamos en la
era del homo tecnológicos que ha cogido
en sus manos las riendas de la propia
evolución y mediante la ciencia y la
técnica nos va a guiar hacia una mejora
de la especie humana
de hecho se define como ese movimiento
cultural que reúne a científicos
biólogos físicos expertos en
inteligencia artificial nanotecnología
que justamente se plantean esto la
mejora permanente de la especie para
erradicar aspectos indeseables como el
dolor el sufrimiento e incluso la muerte
desafían la muerte con la criogenización
este paradigma representado por autores
no estamos hablando de cuatro personas
perdidas no no estamos hablando de una
asociación humanity plus se llaman hoy
entre cuyos ideólogos está el profesor
nick bostróm que dirige el centro para
el futuro de la humanidad de la
universidad de oxford y que plantea este
nuevo paradigma paradigma antropológico
de mejora de la especie humana mediante
la ciencia y la tecnología para ir a un
trans humano mejorado con más
capacidades cognitivas físicas para
llegar al final dice él en uno de sus
artículos afirma se extinguirá a la
especie humana se extinguirán los trans
humanistas y llegaremos a una especie
post humana bien podríamos hacer un
montón de consideraciones de carácter
filosófico de carácter perdón
tecnológico acerca de las posibilidades
reales de llevar a cabo esto y también
de carácter ético pero antes de hacer
ese análisis ético desde la perspectiva
de la bioética
quiero decir brevemente cuáles son de
qué manera quiere lograr esto el trans
humanista el trans humanista lo que
hacer en primer lugar mediante la
genética
a día de hoy ya sabéis que tenemos la
edición genética el cris ver mediante el
cual podemos es una especie de corta y
pega genético podemos quitar un gen
claramente sabiendo que a día de hoy no
controlamos el patrimonio genético y por
tanto quitamos ese gen y podemos hacer
que la generación sucesiva la
descendencia no tenga o padezca una
determinada enfermedad también mediante
el alargamiento de los telómeros para
alargar la esperanza de vida de un
embrión esta es otra posibilidad que ya
de hecho se hace en el cen yo aquí en
madrid' alargan triplica en la vida de
los ratones esto imaginaos hacerlo en
seres humanos también mediante fármacos
que modulen nuestro carácter nuestra
personalidad mediante sustancias que
modulen los afectos la ingesta de
oxitocina por ejemplo plantean también
mediante implantes nanotecnológicos en
nuestro cerebro y en distintas partes de
nuestro organismo para modificar y
mejorar capacidades bio físicas
cognitivas en todos los niveles esto ya
es un hecho hay ven sean el harbisson y
alguna otra persona que se ha
incorporado ellos se llaman cyborg
aunque aquí bueno cuestionar y amos que
entendemos por cyborg yo considero que
son humanos personas con implantes el
cyborg es una entidad biológica orgánica
y cibernética pero que en su origen no
es humano esto sería un humano con
implantes también plantean entre otras
cosas lo que se llama el interfaz
cerebro ordenador seguramente han oído
ustedes hablar de neuro link neural inc
perdón un producto que se está
elaborando en nuestros días para
aumentar las posibilidades de
intercambio de información entre nuestro
cerebro y el ordenador
para en un futuro no necesitar el cuerpo
directamente del cerebro podremos hablar
podremos realizar ciertas actividades
incluso a la inversa podrían incluso
llegar a hackear no es el cerebro
haciendo que pensemos o que elijamos de
una determinada manera también con la
criogenización post morten que plantean
los trans humanistas es decir
introduciendo en el momento de la muerte
o justo antes de morir sustancias que
preserven el cuerpo para resucitarlo
dentro de 100 años por ejemplo
a la postre hablan también de el
trasvase de todo el contenido sináptico
a un ordenador para tener existencias
post biológicas tras la muerte este es
el escenario que plantean los trans
humanistas quizás algunos de ustedes ya
habían oído hablar
por supuesto a todo esto digamos en la
revolución biotecnológica en la
revolución neuronal el conocimiento de
todo eso se une todos los conocimientos
de inteligencia artificial todo el big
data y toda la cantidad de información
que habremos generado y en la fusión de
esas tres revoluciones la biotecnológica
la neuronal y la de digital o la de la
inteligencia artificial el poder
sumatorio va a ser mortal
claro cuando uno habla de transhumanismo
y llevo diez años estudiando leyendo a
estos autores realmente surgen muchas
perplejidades acerca en primer lugar de
las posibilidades reales científicas de
hacer todo eso porque a día de hoy
muchas de esas cosas no son posibles y
no son seguras pero sobre todo de los
planteamientos antropológicos que
subyacen somos realmente una máquina que
se perfecciona a base de complementos
nanotecnología o somos algo más escriba
nuestra felicidad solamente en la
perfección biofísica
todos tenemos experiencia de conocer a
personas que son imperfectas
aparentemente que están en una silla de
ruedas o tienen una discapacidad física
y son muy felices y viceversa personas
muy perfectas físicamente que son muy
infelices la felicidad humana no estriba
solo en la percepción biofísica porque
no somos solo y exclusivamente
claramente esto tendría tendríamos que
demostrarlo más ampliamente y no es el
lugar pero no somos solamente una
máquina muy perfecta somos algo más y es
aquí donde viene y llega digamos en
ayuda la bioética la biótica como una
reflexión una disciplina que nace hace
50 años que se plantea todos los
problemas éticos de las intervenciones
sobre la vida humana animal y vegetal
para ver qué efectos van a tener tanto
en la persona que la realiza como en el
sujeto que lo padece como en las
generaciones futuras la biótica es a su
vez interdisciplinar reúne conocimientos
de ciencia de ética o reflexión más
humanística y de derecho y otras
disciplinas
para hacer una decisión conjunta que nos
permita comprender ver bien perdón
cuáles son las implicaciones éticas de
todas esas intervenciones la bioética es
esa reflexión que nos hace ponderar bien
nuestros actos para ver si realmente
llevan a la humanidad a ese progreso si
todo desarrollo tecnológico puede
llevarnos a un progreso de la humanidad
y no solamente de un individuo o de un
estado o de una empresa sino del
conjunto de la humanidad claramente la
bioética se plantea ya haciendo una
reflexión sobre el transhumanismo y
sobre cuáles son las posibilidades
científicas que tenemos de mejorar de
superar esos límites que es la reflexión
que quería traeros aquí hoy creo que se
ha de hacer siempre y aquí doy unas
cuantas claves de la bioética se debe
hacer siempre salvaguardando una serie
de bienes y derechos fundamentales en
primer lugar no dañar no hacer daño
ninguna intervención que daña a un
individuo a las generaciones futuras
debe o debería de alguna manera
realizarse la deberíamos hacer con
muchísima precaución con muchísima
prudencia
la salvaguarda de la integridad física
de las personas de la salud física y
psíquica de las personas sobre todo
pensar de los grupos más vulnerables
estoy pensando en las personas con
discapacidad o las personas mayores
y personas que todavía no tienen los
medios ni siquiera para sobrevivir en
qué manera van a aparecer estas mejoras
que se van a aplicar sobre todo por
cierto en occidente y en países
desarrollados en segundo lugar todo lo
que tiene que ver con la salvaguarda de
la libertad y la conciencia de las
personas claramente todo ese poder que
va a tener estoy pensando en neural in
por ejemplo esa empresa que va a tener
toda esa información de nuestro cerebro
que uso se va a hacer de yo voy a ser
realmente dueño absoluto de todo ello o
quién lo va a utilizar
también todo aquello que tiene que ver
con la justicia con la igualdad que no
haya eugenesia que no haya selección de
los que tienen menos capacidades
es decir todos estas cautelas éticas son
aquellas que hemos de considerar no ya
en el transhumanismo que como habéis
bien comprendido soy crítica con él en
sus objetivos aunque no crítica con todo
lo que plantea porque algunas de las
mejoras son mejoras con una finalidad
terapéutica y pueden considerarse como
algo positivo no habrá que ver cada una
de esas intervenciones y realmente
llevan a la mejora integral del ser
humano todo ello además con un principio
de precaución respecto a las
generaciones futuras al ecosistema a
otros tipos de vida pensando que somos
el único ser vivo sobre la tierra que es
capaz que tiene responsabilidad sobre el
resto de los seres vivos que es capaz de
cuidarlos de preservar de tener de
pensar en su futuro esto es a lo que se
dedica la bioética creo que es muy
importante a día de hoy aquí he traído
esta frase de uno de los pioneros de la
bioética bandas en la en poder no
confundir con harry potter que escribió
en los años setenta uno de los primeros
ensayos de bioética la bioética la
ciencia de la supervivencia
y me gusta esta expresión siempre la
utilizo porque creo que es muy
inspiradora no en el sentido que la
bioética considerada como la sabiduría
de la ciencia una reflexión sapiencial
en torno al sentido de las mejoras al
sentido de la ciencia al para que no
solamente al como lo vamos a hacer sino
al para qué porque cuáles son los
riesgos las consecuencias que vamos a
asumir con todo ello y es aquí y con
esto ya concluyó justamente mi propuesta
mi propuesta es que en las próximas
décadas tenemos que pensar a 500 años
vista hacer el ejercicio mental pensar
hacer el ejercicio mental de una persona
medieval que de repente llega a nuestra
época imaginaos estaría desconcertado
alucinado con todo lo que un avión que
vuela los coches la velocidad hacemos
ese mismo ejercicio trasladándonos
nosotros dentro de ocho siglos pensando
que el desarrollo de la ciencia va a ser
exponencial cada vez más rápido ya no
llegamos no llegamos a alcanzar todos
los avances que se van produciendo y al
mismo tiempo se está produciendo
la sabiduría la reflexión antropológica
ética jurídica está yendo por detrás se
hizo la clonación en su día y no había
leyes al respecto se han hecho embriones
mejorados
y no ha habido legislación al respecto y
de hecho se ha planteado una moratoria
general internacional respecto a esto
que haya creo y en esto es la apuesta
importante que haya una reflexión
sapiencial profunda ética antropológica
acerca de hacia dónde vamos y cómo
queremos llegar es decir el problema no
es tanto si vamos a superar los límites
porque los vamos a superar no cabe duda
de aquí a 500 años y eso es fantástico
el problema es justamente si los vamos a
superar de forma que respetemos al ser
humano respetemos a las otras especies
respetemos nuestro entorno y que
realmente lo hagamos con sabiduría es
decir la superación de esos límites de
forma sabia para no olvidar que
realmente la ciencia y la técnica nacen
como productos humanos para transformar
la realidad para mejorar el bienestar de
toda la especie para llevar a plenitud
al ser humano no solamente en términos
estrictamente biofísicos sino en toda su
integridad
solamente así con esto termino
llegaremos a cumplir el clásico ideal
pindar y ccoo
el siglo quinto antes de cristo antes de
cristo
llega a ser quien eres aprende y llega a
ser quien eres muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]